VQEアルゴリズムの成功は大きく
最初に選ぶ状態とcircuitに
かかってる。
私はVictoria Lipinskaで、この動画では
その選択肢を探っていく
設計の方法について。
VQEの量子部分の
毎回の実行に含まれる
すべての要素を詳しく見ていこう。
まず参照状態、
別名初期状態から始める。
参照状態を
パラメータ化されたcircuitに通す。これを
変分形式と呼び、
パラメータの初期値を使う。
そしてその状態を
ハミルトニアンの基底で測定する
circuitを通した後に、
期待値を得るためだ。さて
これらの要素を一つずつ見ていこう、
まず参照状態から。
参照状態の典型的な選択は
ゼロ状態だ。
つまり量子コンピュータが
既に初期化されている状態のことだ。
量子化学の問題では、
いわゆるHartree-Fock状態を
使うこともできる。
これはHartree-Fock法の
結果だ。
簡単に言うと、Hartree-Fock理論は
参照状態を構成する簡単な方法を与える
量子系の基底状態を近似することで
参照状態を構築する。
状態空間内での
回転を見つけ、
基底状態エネルギーを
最小化する。
最後に、参照状態は
問題に非常に特有のものになることもあり、
カスタム状態を
選びたい場合もある。
系がどんな性質を持つか分かっている場合、
例えば対称性や
状態内の電子数が
特定されているなら、それを使って
VQEアルゴリズムの
収束をより良くできる。
良い参照状態を選ぶことは
収束のために重要で、
基底状態に近い
参照状態は
問題をずっと簡単かつ
速く収束させることができる。
同様に重要なのが
初期パラメータ値の選択で、
変分形式に入力するものだ。
つまり、参照状態と初期パラメータ次第で、
速く収束したり、遅くなったり、
全く収束しなかったりする。
このプロットを見てみよう。
視覚化のために、
パラメータ空間が
パラメータ一つだけだと想像しよう。
非常に良い参照状態なら
かなり近いところから始められ、
最終的な基底状態に近いので
収束が速くなる。
一方、基底状態から
非常に遠いところから始めると、
参照状態aでは、
高いエネルギー障壁を越えなければならず、
収束が非常に遅くなったり
全く収束しなくなる。
これについてはこのコースの
古典的最適化モジュールで
より詳しく議論する。
次に参照状態に作用する
パラメータcircuitを見てみよう、別名
変分形式だ。
このcircuit、つまりthetaのUが参照状態に
作用すると、
試行状態と呼ぶものが得られる
psi of theta、別名ansatzだ。
このansatz状態が
適切な基底で測定され、
エネルギーの期待値を
得るためだ。
ここで議論する
変分形式は
化学に動機づけられている。
ただし、量子機械学習に
インスパイアされたものも
あることを忘れずに。
そして他の近距離型の
アルゴリズム、例えば量子近似
最適化アルゴリズムなどもある。
化学ansatzのよくある選択肢について
いくつか見ていこう。
ユニタリ結合クラスターまたはUCC
は、最初のVQE論文で
最初に提案された手法だ。
量子化学の問題で
よく使われている。
通常、量子状態をパラメータ化する際、
指数関数的に多くの
パラメータを扱う。
しかし、準備用circuitを
効率的にするには、
多項式数の演算が
必要だ。
したがって、多項式数の
パラメータも必要になる。
UCCは、そのようなcircuitで
試験状態を準備する方法の例だ。
これは結合クラスター法から
導かれており、
量子化学の
ゴールデンスタンダードだ。
最も一般的な選択は
ユニタリ結合クラスター
singles and doublesの
ansatz、略してUCCSDだ。
UCCSDは問題の特定の電子配置に
動機づけられているため、
システムを適切に反映した
参照状態が必要だ。
これがHartree-Fock状態だ。
UCCSD ansatzは通常、基底状態の
良い近似を与える。
与えられた分子における単一および二重の
電子励起を捉えるからだ。
UCCSDのパラメータ数は
スピン軌道の数に対して
二乗でスケールする。
UCCSDは問題に
非常にうまく適合できるが、
残念ながら二乗スケーリングは
依然として非常に深いcircuitにつながる。
それは現在の量子コンピュータには
難しい。
そこでIBMの研究者たちは
より発見的なアプローチを提案した。
変分形式を基盤となる
ハードウェアに合わせられる方法だ。
その結果、効率的に
実行可能なcircuitが得られる。
つまり、試験状態はquantum gateによって
パラメータ化されており、
利用可能な物理デバイスに
適応している。
これは非常に発見的なアプローチで、
ハードウェアフレンドリーだ。
これらの例をもとに、可能性の
スペクトルを見てみよう。
変分形式を表現するために
持てる選択肢だ。
これらの多くはすでに
Qiskitに実装されている。
ぜひ自分で試してほしい。
解こうとしている問題に
最も適したものを。
グラフを見ると、一方では
非常に発見的な
変分形式がある。
問題固有性は低いが、
実際のハードウェアで実装できるよう
設計されている。
また高い表現力も持っており、
その意味は
多くの量子状態を
表現できるということだ。
しかし、後の段階で
起こりうる問題は
古典的最適化の段階で
遭遇する
いわゆるbarren plateauだ。
次のモジュールで説明する。
一方では、非常に問題固有の
ユニタリ
結合クラスターがある。古典的化学では
優れた成果を上げているが、
大きなcircuitの深さのせいで量子
ハードウェアへの実装が難しい。
一般的に、計算をより
うまく進めるには、
まず参照状態と
パラメータの初期値を選んで
基底状態に近いansatz状態を
作るのが大切だ。
次に、不要なパラメータは避けること。
そういったパラメータは
見返りなしにcircuitの深さを増やすか、
より大きなパラメータ空間を
生み出すことになる。
それを探索すると、古典的な最適化に
プラトーが生じる。
どのパラメータが必要かというのは
慎重に考えが必要な
問題固有の問いだ。
名誉ゲストである
Hamiltonianがこの中のどこに潜んでいるか話そう。
前のセクションで学んだように、
qubitマッピング後のHamiltonianは
重み付きPauli演算子の
文字列の和として表される。
ただし最終的には、
variational formが生成した
ansatz状態における
Hamiltonianの期待値を求めたい。
幸い、量子力学は
都合よく線形だ。
それを使って
期待値を求める。
仕組みはこうだ。
HamiltonianはPauliの
重み付き和だとわかっている。
線形性により、
和の期待値は
各Pauli文字列の期待値の
和に等しい。
これは素晴らしい。もうご存知のように、
Pauli基底での測定は
標準測定基底の
回転と同じくらい簡単だ。
この巨大なHamiltonianの
期待値を和として直接測定する代わりに、
まず個々の項の期待値を求めて、
最後に対応する重みをかけて
足し合わせる。
だから多くの資料では
ansatzの後にシングルqubit回転だけが
見られる。
これがcircuitの実行のたびに
Hamiltonianを実装するものだ。
次の動画では、
古典的な最適化ステップで
何が起きるかを探っていく。
またそこで会おう。